you've talked about that you first began
to
reconsider the negative health myths
around psychedelics when you learned
that the book
one flew over the cuckoo's nest was
written by ken kezie when
he was in part under the influence of
lsd so
how do you think lsd helped him ken keys
in
writing uh that incredible book
yeah there's a process that's called
semantic priming and so what what that
means is that
i say um night you say day you know
there's kind of
normal patterns of kind of you say one
word
what kind of words come to you next
and so they've done some research they
meaning scientists have done some
research
where you give people a psychedelic
and then you do this semantic priming
and
what you find is they have a wider range
of associations
than they normally would when they're
not under psychedelics
so i think for ken kesey um
he was able with psychedelics to get
like um a deeper kind of emotional
connection to some of these
states of mind that people were in the
instant this mental institution
and that he could explore them more
in-depth and more eloquently and and
and also one of the things he talked
about was the fog machine
was you know how people's minds were
sort of clouded by the people that ran
the institution and this
the fog machine would be coming in so i
think
the imagery and the metaphors
that he used a lot in the book could
come to him during lsd experiences and
and then now he wasn't doing um you know
very when you're writing you have to be
literate you have to be able to write
you know so it would be more like
beginning and ends of lsd trips instead
of at the peak
but i think you would get a lot of these
um
the feeling tones or the images the
metaphors i think he would get
these extent also lsd lasts so long you
can get these extended focus
and you can really elaborate on
images and so much of psychedelic
experiences
are poetic and metaphorical i mean you
can take um
you know veterans who've never
[Music]
read a book of poetry in their lives
you know and under the influence of mdma
just
what they describe the imagery and the
way they describe their experience is
metaphorical poetic it's incredible
um and so i i think that um
ken kesey was able to to channel these
what lsd did to his mind in a way
that most people couldn't do
but he did because he was trying to
write this novel and because he was so
brilliant
you